so breaking news out of Nigeria where
there are reports that dozens of people
have been killed in a church attack it
happened in the southwestern town of oo
gunmen are believed to have entered the
Saint Francis Xavier Church during
Sunday service ahmedris is across all
developments he's joining us from Abuja
with the latest on this attack Ahmed
they're in there is no statement yet
from the security forces as to who was
responsible for this attack and what
exactly happened or how many people have
been killed there have been several
figures that have been going around in
the media circles the online mediums we
have here some are quoting as many as 50
people have been killed but that is
totally unconfirmed at the moment some
are even saying that the figure could be
much much higher because of the injuries
inflicted on worshipers at the church in
OVO now the president and the state
Governor have both issued statements
condemning the attack but again like we
said at the introduction we don't know
exactly who carried out that attack
similar attacks have been going on in
the north northern and Central parts of
Nigeria for a very long time now
especially in the northwest of Nigeria
carried out by armed groups called the
bandits by the way have been declared as
terrorists by the Nigerian government
it's not clear whether these armed
groups have infiltrated the southwest of
the country tree and carried out this
attack at the moment but again we know
over the past few years there have been
several clashes between local farmers
and cattle herders in that area at some
point the states in the region have set
up their own Vigilantes and chased out
these cattle orders in that area it's
not clear whether these are the groups
responsible for this attack but again
this is election year other people are
of the opinion that this could have or
this could have something to do with
politics however nothing is totally
confirmed at the moment it could be a
criminal gang that is out to carry out
that attack and whatever it is that
group really intended to cause as much
as as much casualties as possible
because what we understand is uh the
first of all detonated devices and
forced worshipers panicked worshipers
run out of the church and as they run
out they open fire on them killing them
instantly among the dead are children
women and old people who went for church
services on Sunday
um so what does the government been
doing about
the increased the worsening violence
rather by armed groups in the country
they've been they've been putting out
several Fires at the same time during
but the fact of the matter is that the
United Security forces are really really
overstretched dealing with these issues
zamfara state has been going for close
to 10 years now remember Boko Haram has
been there for more than 12 years and
several other uh clashes have broken out
over the past few years over the last 10
or 15 years especially in the North and
North Central parts of the the country
and also there have been ethnic clashes
among people various people across the
country and the security forces are
really really struggling to deal with
these problems and what makes matters
worse for them is the infiltration
alleged infiltration of foreign Fighters
into the crisis that are happening in
Nigeria at the moment uh the former the
current chief of Defense staff announced
that the security forces especially the
military has deployed in almost all 36
states of the country and com going by
the number of security forces in this
country these are the numbers are really
really inadequate to deal with these
problems we're talking about a country
with a population of 200 million plus
people and these are areas that have
been targeted for a very long time
clashes similar clashes between uh
religious ethnic as well as personal
interests or other political interests
have been going on for in this country
for a very long time during okay thank
you so much Ahmadi is reporting from
Abuja